somebody who probably doesn't frequent
bass pro shops either is joining the
show right now howard beck from sports
illustrated with
nba free agency uh kicking off today
howard when was the last time you were
in a bass pro shop
um i'm gonna say never probably
you know fishing fishing culture is big
in the nba paul george big fisherman
not not a part of the of your life
growing up in the beck household huh
uh i i'm not an angler do they still
call themselves anglers
anglers oh yeah yep okay um i don't know
what angles have to do
with angling i don't it's it's all a
mystery to me i i
i might have fished once or twice when
you know back when i was a kid we went
like
camping or something uh it's been a
while since i had a rod in my hand
and was casting anything anywhere so
yeah um i think we just came up with a
new show howard i think we need to see
nba basketball journalists survivor
who do you think would win that show
i've already lost apparently
yeah no you're an early exit from from
the tribe but who do you see uh
surviving the campfires and
and winning nba journalist survivor
oh man that's good um
i'll have to think on that for a little
bit i have to think on that for the
certainly uh so you know probably one of
the younger
generation right like i'm you know i'm
up i'm up there like i'm just gonna get
you know thrown overboard real early on
um
so worldwide rob you think or count on
vic on twitter could live off the land
yeah exactly exactly but you know
everybody does the job a little
differently right so some people are
just real great operators um
and so would find a way to just kind of
connive their way to the
end whether or not they had these skills
to survive right
and that's really what those shows are
about you don't have to be the best at
any given thing you just have to
find a way to manipulate everybody else
so like we could get really deep in the
weeds on that and i'd probably offend
everybody that i ever worked with in an
nba press room
so um yeah so i think that's what i'd
like to do for the rest of the
conversation
do you think rick buker can be trusted
i'm definitely not trusting buke he'll
he'd
did not expect to get these type of
questions no no we're on any show
nor did i expect to do that but howard's
an old buddy we did uh gm school
together for nba tv which was a fun show
uh
about a year and a half ago now at this
point um where we were concentrating
that we did yes almost the last thing we
did before shut down i did that and then
i went to sloan conference
in in boston a little a few days after
that then and then
and that was it those were literally the
last two things i did outside of my
apartment the first person i remember
who didn't feel comfortable shaking
hands with me because of germs and
corona was sam mitchell i just remember
sam mitchell
was the first guy giving out pounds
about it yes he was like he wanted to
bump like ankles
that was about it that was the extent of
it and and we were thinking i don't
remember
how you reacted but my thought back in
the green room with sam mitchell was
like
all right dude i get it but chill like
it's not that bad
like you're being a little bit overboard
here because little did we know
it was you know and that was a thing
like it wasn't even about shaking hands
it was like don't breathe each other's
air but you know we knew nothing on
march 10th or whatever that was
when we were uh silly you know stupidly
hanging out
and you know filming tv shows no let's
make sure that history doesn't revise
itself while the country didn't know how
to handle the pandemics sam mitchell was
on top of it sam mitchell
absolutely we should have made him the
uh the public health star
mitchell the new dr fauci um uh howard
beck joins the show ben line's in
uh for rich on the rich eisen show well
i talk about gm school because that show
was all about aspiring front office
executives learning how
nba teams and rosters are built and put
together well now we get real
gm school now it's august 1st the new
july 1st
so with uh 52.6 million dollars in cap
space the knicks have the most cap space
this offseason
who else do you see spending some money
and making some real moves that you
think
might shake up the culture of their team
yeah i mean a lot of eyes on the knicks
because they have this unexpected
breakthrough
season overachieved by a lot and and
you know that's to their credit um but
they also did it in a way where you look
at the rosters and you're not sure
how sustainable it is because it's not
like it was a lot of talent so you
credit them for how much they got
out of what limited talent they had but
now you've even raised the bar that much
more
in the expectations that much more for
what comes next so
you've got all this cap room more than
anybody in the league you are in one of
the
greatest markets possible to attract
free agents
can you overcome it was it enough in one
year under tibs and leon rose
to overcome the you know years and in
fact decades of of infamy and and you
know creates
actively avoiding that franchise do do
people feel better about them now enough
to take the money but the other problem
is is a more fundamental one which is
okay let's say that
this is a great destination now the
knicks and free agents want to come
there's just not a lot at the top tier
to attract
so if you're looking for you know julius
randle's ideally a number two not a
number one so if you're looking for a
number one well i just don't know any of
those guys
are available can you find another guy
who's at you know julius randle level or
a couple of like
really solid kind of just a tear below
all-star
and there are good players available but
this is not a great year for free agency
so their their cap
room they either have to decide to roll
it over to next year
and and and you know reserve some of
that for when you might get a crack at
some bigger stars or um you'll go you're
going short
term going one one year deals with guys
um
or there are other creative ways to use
it right you can make uneven trades and
absorb guys into cap room but again
who's available is dame lillard gonna
become available
as of now still doesn't look like it
bradley beal all indications are that
he's
staying put and so you know i i don't i
don't know who they get at this point
um you know then there's you asked who
else is going to make a big splash i
mean the lakers already have
in in making that agreed upon deal for
for westbrook
i'm not sure i i'm not sure i'm
convinced that that's
a deal that moves them forward um
but it's certainly a flashy deal howard
beck joins the show
sports illustrated and uh an early front
runner on
nba journalist survivor uh we were
talking about another team that that's
got some cap space this year 33 and a
half million dollars worth
uh are the dallas mavericks and
everybody on this show loves luca
they're on the luca 77 diet of beige
food and cigarettes
what do you think the mavericks do
around luca
well they've been one of the teams that
for months
have been well let's go back before
months oh you know if you go if you roll
back the calendar for a year
they were a team that was positioning
themselves to try to chase giannis
before giannis had signed the max
extension
dallas miami toronto those those were
all teams that were hoping to put
themselves in position
to steal giannis that's obviously not
going to happen
so then the fallback for all those teams
um
has been you know a variety of other
guys and you know i don't think anybody
really thought
even if you were healthy the kawhi
leonard was going to leave la it
still looks like you know you know
injured and rehabbing from from acl
surgery
that kawhi leonard probably stays and
would you want to sign a guy that would
you that you
thought was probably missing the entire
season anyway so for the mavericks you
know kyle lowry would be a phenomenal
addition
all indications in the last you know 24
to 48 hours or that miami
is positioning itself to be in position
to grab lowry and nothing certain until
it happens
but if they get him you know again now
the mavericks
are in a position where you know where
where else do you go you probably resign
tim hardaway jr he's become very
important for them
they need help up front you know are
they a destination for somebody like a
rashaan holmes
um you know is there you know there are
other other guys that they could
um pry loose to bolster the front court
next to porzingis
but they do need another playmaker like
so much is in lucas hands and that's
that's generally a good thing luca does
a lot of great things with the ball in
his hands scoring and play making but
you need to give him a little bit of
relief and so if not lowry
maybe there are spencer didn't what he
did uh lo you know a destination
maybe they find their way into the lonzo
ball discussions um
you know mike conley if he were to leave
utah but nobody believes that's going to
happen
so i i do think that that's probably top
of the list though for them
is another playmaker to relieve some of
the burden on on luca
howard beck joins the show sports
illustrated ben lyons filling in for
rich on the rich eisen show howard
you've been covering the game at such a
high level
for so many years you're as dialed in as
anybody so you're probably familiar with
the fact that it's a
kind of a foregone conclusion in nba
circles that
zion williamson's going to come save the
new york knicks do you think the
pelicans do anything to try and keep
zion what happens with lonzo and what do
they do in new orleans
working on their third coach now under
uh three years with zion williamson
spoken like a true new yorker i'm just
putting out the sources and the things i
hear from sources around the league
because i'm like you howard i'm just a
guy who's been around the league a long
time you know
um it's never too early to tie up and
coming superstars to the mix it's just
never too early
zion of course has totally encouraged
that by getting all
you know cutesy and winky with the media
about talking about all the gardens love
laying in the garden
um it's way too soon for this like way
way way too soon even by by
new york media standards for for that
stuff i mean
nobody in the history of the nba since
you know this current structure was
created with max contracts and a rookie
deal then you to get your first max deal
after that
no one's ever turned down the max deal
that comes after your rookie contract if
you're an upcoming superstar and zion
williamson
will not be the first he's not going to
force his way out the next couple years
so
uh he's in he's heading into year three
then there will be a year four that's
also on the option and then your five is
when you can start talking about
extension and everything
he'll to take the extension off of it
just like everybody does and we can talk
about zion williamson
having wandering eyes you know sometime
in the year 2025
26 um but it's it's too soon right now
um i do think the pelicans have a clear
urgency as you always do in this league
when you get a guy
who is a transcendent generational kind
of player
you have the clock is ticking always the
clock is not ticking as loudly for a guy
who's
going into year three as it is for a guy
going into year six or seven
but the clock is always ticking and you
have an obligation and a burden a
responsibility to
build out a competitive roster a playoff
caliber team at minimum as quickly as
possible
and selling them on the idea that you
know what you're doing and that you've
got a direction
and that that direction is going to give
them a chance to contend for titles
and if you don't do that quickly enough
and confidently enough
we see what the consequences are and
that franchise knows better than anyone
because
and it's not the current
administration's not even the current
ownership
but the new orleans team formerly the
hornets now the pelicans
lost chris paul once upon a time back in
2011 and then years later
lost anthony davis um
you know lebron james of course left
cleveland after his first seven years
there
because they couldn't break through and
that was a team that had made the finals
and won
60 games so the pelicans do have a lot
of work to do
and they got to do it quickly and
they're clearly moving swiftly i mean to
their credit
yeah we could say three coaches in three
years but to their credit they realize
the mistake
that that stan van gundy was not going
to work for them uh that he was not the
right fit
and they moved on as quickly as possible
and they saw that stephen adams
was the wrong investment from a year ago
and moved on from him as quickly as
possible we'll see what's next
howard five years ago on july 1st nba
fans were blessed with the signings of
timothy mozgov and lual deng
in los angeles for 150 million dollars
we saw things like alan crabb get four
years 70 million
chandler parsons who had a billboard on
beverly in la cienega
he got 90 million signed his deal in the
nightclub what's going to be the signing
who's going to be the guy this year
that nba fans wake up on august 2nd and
3rd and go huh
how did that happen
i mean the year you're pointing to 2016
was of course the year of the uh
notorious salary cap spike this once in
a
lifetime probably occurrence that um
you know created way too much cap room
and way too many uh mediocre free agents
getting overpaid
i mean there's always somebody but that
summer was its own anomaly
its own weird occurrence just because of
how much cap room
was suddenly available to basically all
30 teams because of that cap spike um
this is not that kind of summer i mean
guys might get overpaid because
there just aren't enough good players in
this free agent market but there also
are a ton of teams with
cap room to spend wildly so um
will somebody overpaid dennis schroeder
yeah maybe
um will somebody you know maybe go a
little overboard on on maybe spencer
dinwiddie because that's the thing we've
got this this good point guard class but
like
chris paul probably stays in phoenix and
mike conley probably stays
in utah and lowry ends up let's say with
miami well then what is dallas doing
about a point guard what is chicago
doing about a point guard what are the
knicks doing about a point guard
um you know that next tier is going to
end up
potentially getting inflated salaries
but not on the order of the
you know uh alan crabbe timothy mozgov
walden kind of
kind of deals from 2016. good so you
mean that eventually the knicks will
stop paying joe kim noah you think
that'll happen in my lifetime or they'll
continue to pay joe kim noah because of
the summer
he's not looked up what the stretch
provision has
left on it for joakim but um
yeah someday joe kim noah will come off
the book some days josh smith will
possibly come off the pistons books
there's a couple of those out there
howard appreciate you taking the time on
a very busy august first for you my
friend thanks for
for spending some of it with us no
absolutely ben thanks for having me
appreciate you
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here